on April seventeenth 2012 film courage
attended the roundtable press interview
for the meg and lawrence kasdan film
darling companion this audio contains
the interview with the trainers of
freeway the dog from darling companion
for more information on darling
companion please visit sony classics
calm forward slash darling companion oh
it's a Sarah his trainer hey did you
talk a bit about Casey sent that friend
enough pasties and rescue sure he is a
rescue team found about eight years ago
we got every busty them from the Las
Vegas animal shelter but he was found by
the shelter in Las Vegas tied to a tree
with the roads embedded into his neck so
he has such a permanent bald spot on the
back of his net worth or not was
embedded into it again okay the
production that said that do you
recognize that the dog had all of the
policies that yeah it's not what you're
looking for it's obviously based on
looks because it's Hollywood so what
attention we're looking for dogs we look
for like the ears like different things
that show personality like we don't
usually think a lot of dogs with with
the pointy ears
Oh only on your part okay why you just
put your feet up good stay like that
just you know whether or not they're
like food motivated like they're like
tweets or like people or just enjoy it
with we rescued on it before that don't
enjoy training working we're gonna
usually when our families and privacy
and friends that they all have also that
we risk but can't quite work out so
sometimes we'll rescue a minute time if
they don't enjoy it so so as
professional dog trainers do it whether
he work enjoys make a point of visiting
the local animal shelter always alone
you know sometimes just go or checkout
line to feel like if you can even looks
good I think we came he was from Las
Vegas because they're a lot of the
traders parents live there or something
something she just she was looking there
and how much time does he spend bonding
with the actors when he um it depends
Ashley didn't have too much time lines
really of but he did gets them some time
with Diane Keaton obviously the more
time the better but you know it's kind
of like what he has with me is what he
needed to help with her so we try to get
a little bit chuckling some treats and I
love and stuff like that it she is a
true dog lover so it may not really
really easy on him cuz he knew that she
like fellow mother than instantly so it
helps and did you purposely kind of keep
him away from kevin kline just a little
bit more perfect person he is actually
very different to Kevin don't you see
Kevin like wat by life giving take you
love you oh yeah say like or so into
Mike Evans like chives are like head of
excuses like very very indifferent to
president
so it's kind of like a joke now but how
authentic yes any one minute purpose 22
buddies yeah it gave you got into
character really good yeah likewise do
you feel like and the artistic begin
isms that makes those results more
popular is this open ears for you yeah
very good news yeah we always love to
see animals in in all movies and
television and stuff it's fantastic not
only that River golden color awards now
yeah yeah really bring us to the fork I
think we have a winner here yeah okay
member okay yeah I would think he would
be strong but most cases particular trip
he has all what we call like all the
basics goodbye down head down head out
on your side both his feet speed back up
lots of things yeah go to go to amar
retrievers and pick things up so it's
quite a bit on your basic movie behave
yeah hi fellow movie grill yeah how many
dogs chewed on quite a few we do quite a
lot of animals that only just dogs cats
birds reptiles or you can a small
collection of animals but you can't keep
everything because if you try and
collect everything you're pulling even
like the animal just diminishes kha so
we keep only what we can handle and
everything we don't have all the copies
work collectively together so if they
need a dog or the look and we need Lois
you know use our animal in clusters of
the trainer so it's a small little
give me another fake I'm garnet well
I'll tell you maybe 15 in the dogs and
the dog park yes you know I don't I
think we have several cash and we have
people now